looking back on a life left behind
this is my id card from fifa
ibrahim rasul was a fifa accredited
football referee in afghanistan
officiating in futsal tournaments
now he's a refugee stuck in a makeshift
camp in bosnia near the border with
croatia
just i want to continue my job just i
want to
back to my normal life
one country in europe
and
i try to
do fix my life again
keeping up ease for the camera is as
close as rasul now gets to his former
career
in reality there's little space in his
life for leisure
the 33 year old has spent four years
getting this far
and is now trying to get to croatia he
says on his last attempt border police
stole his money and told him and those
with him to go home but police court was
he said go to afghanistan go to
afghanistan here is not for animals
uh here is not for dirty people this is
your opinion this is korwasi country and
you you must go back to afghanistan it's
better for your
and
i can
i can't forget that that's what
they use it to us rasul and his child
are just two of thousands of refugees in
the balkans trying to reach the european
union
their hopes of returning to something
like a normal life dented by the
constant obstacles in their path paul
ruiz al jazeera